right now after the less repeated
desperate attempts to silence him
senator josh hawley's fighting back
against cancelled culture yesterday
he penned an op-ed actually aired in
today's paper the new york post
front cover even in which he called for
pushback against the censoring of
you we the american people and knew
today he is calling for an investigation
into the senators who filed an ethics
complaint against him for
legally objecting as well other
democrats have in the past
to election results he wanted an audit
that's all meanwhile big tech censorship
continues as twitter launched a new
program today
allowing any user to add a note to
tweets
they believe are false in order to quote
add
context for other users that's why i'm
off twitter
instagram facebook i'm off them all
better things to do senator josh hawley
his upcoming book the tyranny of big
tech
being published by ragnary after well it
got cancelled and he got cancelled
uh and blacklisted is now available by
the way for pre-order
i don't know if amazon is even selling
it and it will be released
on the fourth senator hawley thanks for
joining us um
i want to go through this you know you
talked about the latest import from
china and i found that interesting
about social credit we know about you
know your credit score
now you're saying you better have the
right opinion so you don't make it
in this i don't know new polite society
of
of the day if you're happen to have a
view that you want to audit an election
because you have all these eyewitnesses
that signed affidavits for example
yeah now we've got uh big tech and the
big corporation sean and league with the
left and what they're basically saying
is listen if you don't hold the right
opinions
then you're not going to be able to be
on social media you're not going to be
able to get a job
maybe you're not going to be able to
communicate if you if you have a small
business you're going to get boycotted
it is an unbelievable attempt by big
business
big tech and the left to try to censor
all dissent to try to shut down
all opposition to try to silence half of
america
and while the democrats talk about unity
in washington they don't want unity what
they want is
total control and these big corporations
are right there with them trying to
achieve it and sean we've got to stand
up and say
we will not bow down to the mob you know
those of us that are in conservative
talk radio
this is not new to us um
efforts to silence and boycott and get
off the air
and pressure campaigns i'll be honest
i've been dealing with this pretty much
my entire career
and we've dealt with it a few of us
anyway here at the fox news channel
we've all
a few of us have had to deal with this
here too and
not only did they want your book
cancelled um
but they also wanted you removed
not not the people of your home state
that voted for you no no no
the mighty elite in the swamp would
decide that
is that off is that now officially dead
where what's the standing on that
well i can tell you i'm not going
anywhere sean i'm going to continue to
represent the people of missouri without
fear
of any mob and without fear of any
liberal democrat who thinks that they
can impose their will
and this is why i say you know listen
the first amendment may protect the
right of my democrat
colleagues to slander me and to lie but
it does not give them the right to try
to abuse the power of the senate
to silence me and silence senator cruz
and others and i'm just not going to
stand for it i mean if they think that
i'm just going to roll over and say oh
just go on ahead
abuse the senate tear down the senate
tear down all of our democratic
traditions
i am not going to stand for it the
people of missouri sent me here to
represent them
that's exactly what i'm going to do and
i'm not going to be intimidated
by the liberal mob you know the where do
you see this
ultimately ending i mean we saw for
example there's now an official criminal
investigation into hunter biden
the new york post was correct
we talked to the repair shop owner on
this program last week
tucker talked to mr bob olinsky and he
gave his story and i've
i've talked to people that have seen the
laptop we have all this
evidence of a quid pro quo with joe and
zero experience hunter getting money
from
if you listen to grassley and and your
colleague senator ron johnson those two
colleagues
you know they talked about russian
oligarch kazakh oligarchs the ukrainian
oligarchs
chinese nationals wire transfers
shopping sprees the bank of china
millions from barista
joe's the vice president and apparently
it goes right to him as evidenced
in this what is on that laptop and then
it gets worse
so we don't apply the same standards and
big tech and just silence conservative
views
yeah big tech of course suppress that
story the new york post story about
hunter biden about
the laptop and and you see what they
want to do i think where does it end
sean
where it ends is we've got to stand up
and say no to the mob because if we
don't
if we don't then conservatives all
across this country will be unable to
speak they'll be unable to do business
they'll be unable to be heard
and we've got to stand up right now and
say enough is enough we will not be
intimidated
well i think your book's going to be
bigger than ever
you can thank uh all the people that
criticized you for it and hopefully
they'll pay more attention to it because
this cancel
culture wokeness whatever you want to
call it
this effort to silence opposing views is
real and it's been going on college
campuses against radio talk radio for
many many years and
now it's spun totally out of control
from the very people that say the most
incendiary things fascinating all right
thank you senator